hallo mein name ist bekanntlich will
kommt mir heute zu einem neuen video rät
wahrscheinlicheren hütte eingeblendet
ruhm tue ich zeige euch heute nehme ich
hier mein aufnahme zimmer da bitte ich
jetzt einfach mal hier auf die hand ich
kann einfach mal an als wenn man
wirklich in dieses zimmer reihen laufen
würde also hier die tür wir tun wirklich
fragwürdig reinlaufen quasi hier auch
das auch noch mit reingespielt man die
tür hinter uns dann stehen wir hier drin
und ihr weg schon datenbank da ist alles
möglich und hier ist alles möglich
weiter vorne rein gekommen ist geht man
als allererstes die auf meinen
schreibtisch zu der direkt hier von
einer großen fenstern steht also wenn
ich immer auf mache wirklich schon hier
in hoch also ich wurde im innenhof
bezwingen quasi nicht schlimm wenn ich
andere gebäude zeige aber ich bin
trotzdem immer wissen vor 70 metern
hielt auch den schreibtisch drauf gucken
wie wir schon okay hier ist eine lampe
einfach mal wenn ich beispielsweise
irgendwie unterschreiben muss oder ein
bisschen arbeiten wir
es ist gerade der hält drauf deswegen
sieht man dass sich nicht bewegte hier
ist dann ein monitor den körper monitor
von wanderungen glaube ich übrigens alle
sachen alles equipment die in die haare
laptop alles mögliche in die
beschreibungen da bin dann so amazon
affiliate links also wenn ihr darüber
verkauft bekomme ich einen kleinen
provision für euch entstehen dabei keine
merck ortsmitte komplett egal auf jeden
fall führt mitten in der beschreibung
verlinkt auf dem mond brauche ich gerade
hier link mein instagram auch hier da
halte ich nämlich laser luca und jetzt
mein youtube kanal nicht geschafft hat
auf einem kanal ich denke dass jetzt ihr
ja ich will dann weiß nun lampen
bestellt weil ich habe 400 port hardy
ist verboten ist zu sperrig und diese
lampen wir machen auch allgemein viel
für wehrpflicht als ich mein wenn ich
mich jetzt mal hier so hinstellen wie
schon das ist einfach perfekt
ausgeleuchtet alle die stehen derzeit
noch oft weise kleinen stative nämlich
werden wir dafür aber noch beschränkt
arme kaufen damit alles noch ein
bisschen kleiner aus
an den monitor ist eine tastatur
angeschlossen
neben einem aus ich werde gar nicht so
ferne und kommen jetzt hier zu dem was
sich die meisten leute interessiert und
zwar an einem pc ich hab nämlich keinen
normalen pc sondern
einfach vom laptop von naso und bei
nvidia tiefer tauchen 70 oder irgendwie
so auf jeden fall größer karte sachen
unter anderem vom zocken deswegen werde
ich bald auch gta red book laden und
wurde ja computer wurde übrigens
verfügung gestellten video also kein
fördergeld mir nicht von wird ich muss
jetzt nichts machen aber die habe
freundlicherweise zugewandt hier in der
ecke steht dann immer meine dslr drauf
bekennen er und 80 d
auf normalen stativ weil ich hoffe dass
früher alles mit der webcam aufgenommen
die let's play war irgendwie stark weil
ich ja schon wetter macht also ein
bisschen dran zoomen für das schon ganz
geil und hier halt irgendwann schreibt
ist das wichtigere war mir halten
kündigt weiter dieses aufnahmen jetzt
endlich mal umgesetzt habe dadurch den
tisch vorstellen kann also ihr seht
schon ich kann nicht wirklich ein knopf
gedrückt halten und ihr hört doch schon
2000 jahre später kann mein schreibtisch
weil wir ihre höhe hochfahren das heißt
nicht auf einer hand auflegen und wo
dann ist alles sohn finger auf
körperhöhe und da kann ich das besser
aufnehmen bin ich ehrlich gesagt bei mir
selber ein bisschen aufgefallen wenn ich
im sitzen auf nebel bin ich nicht so
energiegeladen und hab halt nicht die
möglichkeit einfach durch mit 100 zu
laufen während der aufnahme wurde gegen
wartenberg wichtigen tisch zu holen die
ich zumindest verstellen kann das hier
war jetzt beschreibt der hinterstraße
gezeigt habe dann habe ich ihr einen
riesigen smiley band mit kippen aus dem
gefängnis hatte diese dann habe ich mit
max zusammengestellt irgendwie habe ich
auch gefragt wichtig hinten daran
angebracht haben wir haben einfach hier
in einen nagel durch gerade denn hier
unten immer einlage zum fixieren damit
die quasi einfach dranbleiben noch
einmal ein bisschen dran rütteln der
grund für diese griffen dann bei einer
weiten die akustik also bei dem wenn ich
dagegen spreche dass weitere perfekter
kurz ich hier gar keinen bock mit seinem
komischen an die wand zu machen unseren
normalen geweben finde ich es halt
geschmackssache aber ich finde es halt
so ehrlich gesagt ganz gut gelöst so ich
hab die kisten daran enteignet
merchandise dadurch kann ich noch ein
bisschen vermuten also das hat ganz
viele vorteile
dann habe ich jemandem top box stehen
die erleuchtet nämlich hier eine couch
an die ich mir politiker gekauft habe
ich war ein andere youtuber haben sich
irgendwie couch abgeholt habe ich
gesehen wie videos die dann irgendwie
wird zwei 3000 euro kosten nicht meint
damit auch die ist dafür darin leute
hier sind es meine videos auch ich habe
zum beispiel mit maximal videos
aufgenommen und abends ehrlich gesagt
keinen nutzer unglaublich viel geld
ausgegeben als live couch bin ich
vollkommen aus die kostet 199 euro bei
ikea die kamera umklappen damit dass 190
x 2 meter flachbett allgemeinwissen dass
das hier alles quasi eigentlich das
gästezimmer in einer wohnung ist also
ich habe das früher einfach so gehabt
dass ich mir gedacht okay ich hab voll
bock im büro der gesamten auch nach
draußen stellen schlafcouch hab mir da
frauen kicken geholt weil ihr ganz guten
menschen mit diesen tisch liegen
eigentlich hatten daraufhin beleidigt
habe leberfinger normale arbeit wenn man
wenn die nicht gerade das spiel wird man
wenn man das trinken würde also bin ich
auf die russen nach unten obwohl er
gerade drauf ich wünschte mir eine
sendung freund genannt hat auch keine
grenzen kennt man in skateboard das
letzte potter-film kollegen unterwegs
dann habe ich hier oben einen goldenen
play button hängen und den aufwand film
war das 20 kilogramm haben max und ich
die übelsten dübel reingehauen irgendwie
was plötzlich 15 millimeter oder so und
das problem ist auch dass sie eine
schiebetür ist und wir wussten nicht
wohin die geht und also ich bin so froh
dass letztendlich hängen daran hängende
köpfe aus dem lukas ob die hochhuth
kappe noch das erste modell da drin
steht auch luca mir.de die wird es
demnächst irgendwann geben weil wieder
etwa noch ein paar probleme bei der
produktion
natürlich nicht alle produzieren die
tabla qualität hier wollte ich mir eher
eine kleine zarte hin packen wo man mit
kreide auf land schreiben kann das habe
ich nämlich in vielen restaurants in
köln gesehen dann habe ich nicht
allerdings für so eine bildtafel
entschieden blätter verraten die besser
sind niederlage in köln dem hause becker
r fotos mit freunden konto
ich finde man ist auch eher wenig
gefüllt aber mit der zeit kommen nur
noch wäre dieses dicker dran und so
weiter werden habe ich hier in der ecke
eine pflanze verstehen da hatte ich
keinen bock mit seinen hässlichen jugend
abzuholen finger mich gern in seinem
korb eingestellt daneben ist auch eine
lampe von ikea und beerscheba kd nicht
mehr damals mal bestellt hat dieser
pappaufsteller und da oben ist ein 2d
namen gemacht hat hallo
dieses mal hat mir machen
zusammengestellt vom platz weg bleibt
keine ahnung was und den haben wir auch
in die an vier seiten an die wand
angebot an der stelle noch mal danke an
dich machen und marvin ist einfach der
kerl der die ukulele blog konzeptioniert
hat und da wird auch montag neuer kommen
mit ökologie am start
also schaltet montag einen direkt eine
200.000 plate und einer den kanal luca
und dann hab ich ja noch irgendwie kennt
die fängt da unten dran geht da oben
hoch und die da oben zu enden der ecke
für die lichterkette und die lange da
hinten habe ich übrigens der bedienung
als wenn ich auf ausdrücke geht's auch
wenn ich auch am drücker dann geht an
ich fand einfach ganz schön für ein
video hintergrund dass ihre lampe daran
ist dass da hinten diese beleuchtung die
lichterkette am start sowie begegnet
dort dann nämlich genau nochmal einen
komplett modus da oben stehen einfach
nur bilder daraufhin durch auch mit dem
kollegen ich meine schwester
sonnenuntergang öl breitete sich schnell
auf einer parkbank wir noch ein paar
weitere bilder vom premieren da weiter
wild mit werk dafür ein paar bücher für
wirtschaftsrecht und noch weitere bücher
weitere bücher und hier unten drin ist
komplett haben die video equipment bei
ging der flaggen von timo renz
irgendwelche kabel irgendwelche
verkleidungen im karneval da ist keine
ordnung drin das muss ich vielleicht
erinnern beschriften und irgendwie
verrückt liefert ihren aber da hab ich
es hat alles rein auf dem boden hier
habe ich zwei teppiche aufwand her hat
dann einfach genau die gleichen wie
einfach aneinander gelegt hat wie ihr
merkt schon wer viel hier ist einfach
jetzt hier eigentlich gar nicht wirklich
klar keine werbung für care oder hinten
hält an leute die wie designer warten
holen aber für mich macht ehrlich gesagt
kein würden weil ich hier so günstig und
es hat ein wertverlust zwar noch
überschaubar aber na ja also ich bin
dann einfach nicht einen firma hier
irgendwie krank viel geld reinzustecken
weil ich ja wie gesagt am tag irgendwie
drei stunden drin bin auf jeden fall
diese ecke und das geld offen dass er
auf dem feld theoretisch was ich habe
hier meine regeln nochmal strahler die
wandlung von borries bei der wohnung
dringt hier unten in der ecke eine
steckdose da habe ich einfach eine
steckdosenleiste reingesteckt die wir
noch gar nicht trennen kann ich dann
einfach wenn keiner da dran ist kann ich
dir einfach in die ecke einschieben
quasi was mich auch enorm viele fragen
meine liegt wohl an geschaut was ist
eigentlich hinter dieser schiebetür
ich möchte nicht schlecht duschen
waschbecken oder durch
also einfach bewerben das den wagen
kaffee ist ein wirkliches gästezimmer
aber die im auto mit couch wie kann man
um punkt natürlich auch wenn die letzte
davon kann ich den tag ein eigenes bett
anbieten aber ich kann sagen ich habe
deine couch kann man umklappen dann wird
die lehne quasi nochmals noch weit
matratze davon habt ihr in wasen ja als
wenn einer von euch mal gast bei mir
müssen aber zum appell mich jetzt bisher
allerdings nur die wachen gezeigt die
wirklich schon vorhanden sind ich habe
allerdings wirklich noch besser schnitt
pläne für diese zimmer das werde ich
euch jetzt mal eben kurz vorstellen die
wird ja viel gekauft ist und hier meinen
arbeitsplatz mehr oder weniger eine
weiße wand die wird jeder normale mensch
halt bei platten am rechner fast machen
ich werde dich gedacht hatte ich immer
ganz gut nicht verbraucht gerne weiter
und war wollte ich mich hier eine
fernseher pv monitorhalterung dran
machen und abfahrt wenn man sich hierhin
welt habe ich mich auf die flitsch
gewährt wenn man ihr auf der couch wild
und lukas schneidet dahin total
irgendwie war dann kann man hier halten
fernseher anmachen beziehungsweise
monitor kann man dann darüber klappen
und hatte man sich hier hinstellen kann
man hier wohl einfach wegspritzen hat
wiederum monitor den wir dann einfach
nur umklappen kann ist denkbar wo und
dann können die leute hier halten die
füße trocken oder player oder so wäre
nicht jemand video schneide und wenn wir
dann keinen bock mehr als trocken oder
wir irgendwie findet dass der fernseher
im weg ist der monitor da wenig weil sie
einfach wieder von der positionen so an
die wand fahren dass er wieder dran
geheftet ist an der fernseher halterung
das ist ein plan gehe ich auf jeden fall
demnächst mal an ich weiß nur nicht weil
ich will jetzt nicht irgendwie mittel
400 euro und verkauft nicht ob ich dann
einfach mal 20 30 zoll monitor das
reicht ja auch schon auf 400 euro oder
so also das überhaupt jeden fall eine
sache die ich bin eben anstreben möchte
auch noch kommen wollen da oben ist eine
freifläche viele youtuber machen derzeit
wird in amerika und 90 der polaroid
kamera und machen halt bilder und
fakten die dann da dran das ist mir
allerdings ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
zu teuer deswegen habe ich mir einfach 5
wo einwegkameras bestellt da sind
einerseits die fotos größer und es ist
günstiger und von jeder person die bei
mir zu besuch ist mache ich
grundsätzlich mittlerweile seit drei
vier monaten foto avanti rund diese
fotofallen danach rechte aller oben dran
dass jeder der jeweils über superreiche
meine eltern studienkollegin
irgendwelche anderen youtube
die hängen dann fallen sie irgendwann da
oben an der wand eine kamera doch
irgendwie vier euro und im film hat 50
bilder dabei da oben deutlich vorne
bilder daran das bezahlen ihnen wie
keine ahnung unter 20 euro für diese
komplette wand wenn ich bin polaroid
bilder machen würde das ganze locker 200
kosten also wirklich neue job das ist
euer diese polaroid filme auf jeden fall
noch da oben hier wollte ich gleich noch
die band two daran machen mit irgendwie
hallo mein name ist luca oder irgendwie
dort und da oben wollte ich eventuell
merchandise vor mir dran hängen also
einfach so drei die nägel reinhauen und
angepöbelt dranhängen und dann
irgendwelche tiefe rudi völler stellt
euch weil sich fordert nicht immer noch
dahingehend verändert dass das model
wandtattoo dran kommt hier ein tv oder
oben ganz viele bilder und da hinten
noch rudi von t shirts ab was aber auch
hier schon von der jugend uhr ich hab
ich jetzt natürlich nicht betragen
gezeigt wie beispiel etwas in meinem
mülheimer oder irgendwie in den
schubladen demokrat jäger zeigen könnte
wäre dass die komplette technik
komplette audio interface alles möglich
da habe ich versichert runter unter den
schreibtisch gebohrt um irgendwelche
verpackungen hier reingepackt das alles
nicht auf dem tisch darauf liegt alle
beim clean haben deswegen beider noch
die schwenk arme anstatt initiativen bei
der beleuchtung und weiteren bevor aber
ich glaube ich langweile euch jetzt nur
noch das wichtig sage ich euch gesagt
alle produkte die beispielsweise sind in
der beschreibung verlinkt also zum
beispiel ring wie der laptop oder meine
kamera und bereit und bevor ich das
video gefallen hat will ich mich über
ein abo von euch freuen da können sie
einfach hier auf den smiley draufklicken
das kostenlos auf einem eingeblendeten
hier unten ist ein weiteres video ersten
leichter gesagt